David is derived from the Hebrew word for 'beloved.'
And according to Urban Dictionary is "a formidable foe to normal people."
Sometimes David likes to ago by "Dave."
Dave was adopted.
The Star of David is a symbol for Judaism.
David was the king of Israel, who's also the King of Scotland--twice.
He was born in Jackson, Mississippi, used to have twelve fingers, picked on me in middle school, and started doing stand-up at the age of 17.
He was once a radio talk show weatherman, has mad chops on the sax, and has two hearts.
David is a sex addict. He practices transcendental meditation and his last name is really Jones.
David is half Korean, runs a CrossFit gym, and has two cats- Edith and Ohio. (meow)
David was the best thing about the movie 'Prometheus'.
He's a famous singer in Germany and he has a pretty sweet ride.
David is in Panama, California, Kentucky and Nebraska.
David has his own camp.
He's a work of art, and a best friend.
Thanks David... or Dave...whatever it is you go by these days.